the 13th chapter is called the fourth
frontier and indeed um on on rogan this
week we talked about this some so um you
in fact summarized
um the frontiers that we were talking
about having existed before and what the
fourth frontier might be but i'm just
going to read
the section i'm starting a couple pages
into the chapter
again the final chapter of our book a
hundred gatherers guide to the 21st
century
humans thrive in almost every
terrestrial habitat on earth we are a
broadly generalist species with highly
specialized individuals who have
shape-shifted and niche shifted into
nearly every environment on the planet
this has meant interacting with
frontiers over and over and over again
here we describe three types of
historical frontiers geographic
technological and transfer of resource
then we'll propose a fourth
geographic frontier is what we tend to
think of when frontiers are invoked the
vast unspoiled vistas the abundant and
yet uncounted resources
all of the new world north and south
america the caribbean and every island
near the coasts was a vast geographic
frontier for the baringians
the frontier of the new world was
fractal so the descendants of the first
americans discovered even more to the
iwanichi indians yosemite valley
yosemite valley was a geographic
frontier to the taino the caribbean was
a geographic frontier to the sultan
people of far southern chile
tierra del fuego was a geographic
frontier
technological frontiers are moments when
innovation allows a human population to
make more or do more or grow more than
they did before the innovation occurred
every human culture that has terraced
hillsides decreasing runoff and in crop
production was confronting technological
frontiers from the inca and the andes to
the malagasy on the oat plateau of
madagascar
the first farmers in china mesopotamia
and mesoamerica were doing so and the
first ceramicists who dug clay formed
into useful shapes and fired in kohl's
were doing so as well
finally there are transfer of resource
frontiers
unlike geographic and technological
frontiers transfer of resource frontiers
are inherently a form of theft
when people from the old world came
across the atlantic and landed in the
new they may have at first imagined that
they had stumbled upon a fast geographic
frontier but they hadn't
in 1491 the new world is estimated to
have had between 50 and 100 million
people in it with uncountable distinct
cultures and languages
some people were living in city-states
among astronomers craftsmen and scribes
others as hunter-gatherers
to francisco pissarro the inca empire
was a transfer of resource frontier
to the instigators of the rubber boom in
western amazonia at the end of the 19th
century the sapporo territory was a
transfer of resource frontier and once
the sapporos were thus weakened their
longtime competitors the warranty moved
in as well
in modern times transfer resource
frontiers are everywhere oil drilling
fracking and logging in ancestral lands
predatory lendings with subprime
mortgages and much student debt the
holocaust
one symptom of transfer resource
frontiers is
tyranny
geographic frontiers represent the
discovery of resources heretofore
unknown to humans
geographic frontiers are inherently zero
sum there is a finite amount of space on
this planet of ours and we will reach
the end of it
technological frontiers are the creation
of resource through human ingenuity
technological frontiers are temporarily
non-zero sum specifically positive some
and this can appear to be a permanent
state
but there are physical limits a single
electron is the theoretical minimum
needed to flip from one state to another
in a transistor for instance
transfer of resource frontiers are theft
of resource from other human populations
like all frontiers transfer resource
frontiers are ultimately zero sum
theft has its limits even thieves must
obey physical laws
what choice do we have but to continue
seeking new frontiers and more growth if
our addiction is just a special human
case of a pattern that characterizes all
species that have ever lived are we not
simply condemned to write this
destructive trajectory to the end
we have written this book in part
because we believe the answer to that
question is no
humans are obsessed with growth because
it engenders bigger populations that if
nothing else have farther to fall before
going extinct but large populations also
pose a hazard to themselves so the
resources that enlarge them are finite
or fragile in such cases moderation is
the key but it only works of our drive
for growth our individual perception of
it is sustainably satisfied
we have run out of geographic frontiers
or nearly so
technological frontiers by turns
dazzling and disappointing come with
risks beware chesterton's fence and are
ultimately constrained by available
resources
transfer resource frontiers are immoral
and destabilizing
what then are we to do where to turn to
find salvation in simple terms
consciousness
consciousness can point the way to a
fourth frontier
once again the human niche is niche
switching and consciousness is the
answer to novelty living sustainably on
a finite planet is a hard sell but we
can and we must find a way we have no
choice
these problems of novelty require
humanity's urgent attention and cannot
be solved by the good will or hard work
of individuals
we moderns have become a threat to our
own persistence we are built to figure
out how to move between modes of being
it is time to rise to collective
consciousness and prototype a way out of
this
we face some significant obstacles
humans like other creatures are obsessed
with growth
and we are capable of driving ourselves
extinct extinct in the pursuit of it
even though it is logically obvious that
we must accept equilibrium we are not
built to be satisfied with it because
being unsatisfied has been an excellent
strategy for the last several billion
years there is a character trait of
individuals that may be critical to
finding the fourth frontier or rather
it's adaptive foothill that could lead
to a society-wide solution
that is pride and craftsmanship
an artisan who takes pride in the
quality and durability of their work is
enacting some portion of a fourth
frontier mentality one in which the
lifespan of a product is as important as
its function
a table or sideboard made by a local
craftsperson is not beloved merely
because it is more beautiful than what
can be assembled from a box bought at
ikea but also because the person in
possession of a lovely and functional
piece has a chance of handing it down to
their children or other kin or friends
so too would we like to be able to
deliver unto the next generations a
lovely and functional world
the fourth frontier is a framework
therefore that can be understood with an
evolutionary toolkit it is not a policy
proposal the fourth frontier is the idea
that we can engineer an indefinite
steady state that will feel to people
like they live in a period of perpetual
growth but will abide by the laws of
physics and game theory that govern our
universe
think of it like the climate control
that allows the inside of your house to
hover at a pleasant spring temperature
as the world outside moves between
unpleasant extremes
engineering an indefinite steady state
for humanity will not be easy
but it is imperative
i have one more to share
about the maya before we end today but
um
we've ended up
we've done a fair bit of of media so far
most of which is not out there about the
book and
um
i thought we'd end up talking a lot
about the sex and gender chapter and
there have been a few um podcasts that
we've done and we'll be talking about
all these um that have specifically
focused in on that but it's been
interesting how many of them have ended
up being about about this about the
society
level um decoherence uh and how it is
that we can find our way out
well i think it's a mirror actually for
one of the
errors that we point to about
evolutionary theory as we find it today
and uh
i guess i need a little uh a little
leeway here but the idea is
that one has the sense based on what
evolutionists typically say
that evolutionary success is synonymous
with reproduction that producing more
offspring is better and of course we can
back that off slightly but in general
that is the the conventional wisdom and
it's a conventional wisdom for a pretty
good reason which is that
um
the real thing that selection is trying
to accomplish it's not really trying to
do anything but if it were it would be
trying to lodge genes
as deeply into the future as possible
and one way
so zero is what we call an absorbing
boundary if your population goes to zero
it doesn't rebound from it so
one way to not hit zero and therefore
fail to get into the entirety of the
future is to have a lot of individuals
right so reproduction is very closely
tied to many of the things that make you
evolutionarily successful but in and of
itself it's pointless
[Music]
so
the point here is
there are a lot of problems that we face
right that are in some way downstream of
of our perceptions that selection has
awarded us in order that we can navigate
but the purpose of it is all the same
the purpose is to get into the future
and so the reason that many of the
things that we have talked about really
ultimately point to this question is no
matter what problem you solve it doesn't
much matter if you don't solve this one
right we have an obviously unsustainable
trajectory the hazard we now pose to
ourself is so immense that if we don't
solve it there is nothing to do right
you could turn hedonistic and you could
say all right let's just have a party
because there's nothing to be done about
this
and you know there's a reasonable
argument to be made but i think again as
with the question of can you drive this
pathogen to extinction
we don't know there's nothing that has
been provided yet that tells us we can't
get out of this and in fact we the point
the one of the major themes of the book
is that what we do what our species does
what it is built for more than anything
else is getting out of jams and figuring
out what to do in the new situation that
nobody knows anything about that's
that's our niche we're so good at it
even when the jam is one that we are
ourselves have created
but we have now created a series of jams
to use your word uh that we have not
only created but are modifying at such a
rapid rate that it's really hard to see
our way out and we've done some things
that make it less likely so um
the
the problem that we have is we have now
taken what we have as tools and we've
put them in a system that has its own
evolutionary dynamics our political and
economic system causes for example those
who have done something that has created
let's say a technological frontier and
have therefore become very wealthy have
the power to prevent change and so
we talk about this need to rise to
collective consciousness in order to
begin problem solving to figure out how
to get out of the pickle we find
ourselves in but the problem is we now
have an opposing force which is
for anybody who's succeeded brilliantly
change is frightening right because
unless that change is under some kind of
control
if you're a winner change can turn you
into a loser so there is this natural
tendency to frustrate change and the
problem is it won't make it's of no
value to anyone to preserve things in
this state if this state is
self-terminating but there's a game
theory problem where those who oppose
change
actually retain and concentrate their
their fraction of our collective
or their disproportionate fraction of
our our collective well-being and
you know
cynically speaking
even if the world must be saved from
these processes somebody who opts not to
participate in that saving
uh phenomenon
right they actually end up better off
right so the uh the game theory that the
free rider problem applies even within
the category of elites who might group
together and decide to point us in the
right direction
so anyway though our our final chapter
is really about you know what what does
this puzzle really look like if we free
ourselves from the narratives that we
are handed that in large measure
frustrate our ability to see where we
are and where we might go and part of
what you were just alluding to is that
the stable state will not be static that
it is easy for people to conflate stable
with static
and
there will there can be no stable state
for humanity in which humans are
actually feeling
a sense of purpose
and and and progress and happiness and
productivity
which is static and which can
also true that it therefore cannot be
defined uh in advance and um that that
definition will remain the same right
and in fact you know it it will be
subtle to many readers but what we say
about
the fact that this state cannot be
blueprinted we literally do not know
enough to say what the state will look
like what it must be is navigated
towards right that we will learn we will
bootstrap we will prototype our way to
this new state which also implies some
other things and this you know this may
be unsettling to people but this is a
multi-generational
process of navigation right the amount
of change necessary to reach a steady
state that truly does fulfill the human
desire for growth without needing to
find new sources of growth right that
process
let's say it takes three generations
right that means
we're not likely
those who are old enough to be paying
attention to this podcast we're not
likely to
to be in that world right on the other
hand the process of going there we have
been falsely told
would be
a matter of austerity right oh you want
the world to function better and be
safer you're going to have to give up a
lot of stuff and i think this is
complete nonsense that actually we lack
meaning and useful things to do and that
a world in which we actually set about
trying to figure out how the future
should be would be a world in which
there was plenty to do and lots of
meaning and you know the fact that you
don't live to see the final state
doesn't make any difference because it
actually would be a better world almost
immediately upon our setting about this
journey
yeah and asking people in the west
asking people in the weird world
to embrace a policy of austerity from
from here on out
would seem like an obvious ask given our
the relative wealth that we enjoy and
the resources that we have
but it is also true and we write about
this in the book and i've written about
it elsewhere that um the the meaning
that we find in life is mostly not in
our stuff and our our relative wealth
and that it is therefore not in the
weird world where you tend to find the
people who have the most sense of
purpose and meaning and
you know devotion to
to people and love and ideals that that
do provide meaning so
um
giving up
stuff feels really hard for people right
now not because we're a bunch of selfish
greedy
jerks
but because most of us are actually
recognizing at our heart that no matter
how much luxury and comfort we may be
surrounded with there's actually
something real missing so
we can do this with you and i argue but
um
without giving up
a lot of the trappings
but also argue that it's not the
trappings where we're actually going to
find the meaning and what we need to do
is
create a way for people to
refine the connection and the meaning
and of course you know the last i have
to update my calendar but you know the
last 18 months 19 months now has taken
away so many of the opportunities that
people did have you know some of what we
were talking about last time the
the
experiments and the opportunities for
collective joy the the parties and the
festivals and the carnivals and the
sporting events and the intimate
gatherings and the chance meetings on
the sidewalk that turn into a long walk
that turns into an evening that turns
into a relationship right like these
things are much harder to accomplish in
an era of
restrictions and lockdowns and requests
for compliance with rules that have just
been handed to us without an explanation
for their justification honestly
and so what we have had our meaning
taken from us
and that's hardly new but it did
accelerate over these last 18 19 months
and before that as we talk about in the
book
some of the accelerators are you know
the usual suspects the the screens and
the junk everything the junk food the
junk sex the junk entertainment
uh the
the ability of advertisers to hook into
our short-term endocrinological systems
and give us our dopamine hit or
serotonin hit rather than
us being able to resist the dopamine hit
and the serotonin hit and look towards
the the joy and deeper pleasures to be
found in the non-junk versions of food
and sex and entertainment and meaning
making and adventure and creation and
discovery and all of these things
i wanted to
maybe refine one aspect of that because
i do believe that part of our problem uh
with sustainability has to do with the
amount of material and energy necessary
to make the world work and we are we are
going to have to cut back but i the
point i want to make is that is not
going to feel like austerity if done
well right so i want to
raise this issue um buckminster fuller
had a very ironic way of making this
point he uh had this
term
that he coined ephemeralization and his
definition for it was the process by
which you can do more and more with less
and less until eventually you can do
everything with nothing
which you know it's it's a beautiful
fullerism but
in any case the point is think about
something like it almost sounds like
homeopathy though
well the point is the very last bit is
an ironic twist because it is not
absolutely nothing that you can do it
with but the point is it can be
minimized you know a nanomaterial can
have great strength with almost no atoms
in it by virtue of geometry right of the
structures and so anyway i would just
point out this is an evil dangerous
device we all know that right but
at a technological and material level it
is a marvel right how many objects what
does this weigh it weighs you know three
quarters of a pound or something right
and
it's uh
a rather marvelous camera it's a
video camera it's a telephone it's uh
it's a map
finder it's a library like none that has
ever existed on earth right it's a lot
of things that actually don't even have
a name separate from it right or
separate from the revolution that it
accompanied right and so the point is
it's not all the way to a femoralization
it's not a heads up display that emerges
out of no material that you're carrying
around thank god well right but my point
is the number of atoms in this thing is
many but it's not many relative to the
number of objects it replaces and so
it's a lot fewer atoms than an eniac
which did a hell of a lot less
yeah we did effectively nothing um right
i mean it calculated
things like trajectories for bombs and
stuff that you know it's a trivial
calculation by modern standards but
that's the question is how do you
deliver the animal which is what we are
how do you deliver it the somatic
sensation of this is a good safe
functional world in which i am liberated
to do the things that actually make a
difference to me and allow me to make
the world better which is really what
the the objective you know we have this
cruddy system where if it makes a profit
then we sort of imagine that you
probably created wealth there's value in
that
but there's so much market failure where
your profit was made and it really
wasn't that you made the world better
you just externalized harm to somebody
else
its externality is all the way down all
the way down right so many negative
externalities so the question is well
you know
you may not be able to instantiate it
but ideally what you'd like is an
economic system in which you got paid
when you made the world better when you
actually did create wealth and you
didn't get paid for creating negative
externalities or any other exploiting
market failure of any kind and so
um
the real i mean we have two levels of
question
and in fact i once uh
i won't go into it but i do think it's
important to separate out the question
of what structure would make the world
function from the question of is there
any way to get there because the answer
to is there any way to get there could
be no it could be that the obstacles
that those who oppose this because they
find it threatening are too strong and
you can't get there but it doesn't
change the
importance of the question about what
what would a functional system look like
and so anyway we are we are
we need to recast this in the public
mind so that people understand that they
are not being told that they need to
live like monks in order for us to get
into the future because that's not it
they need to
um
retool their expectations a bit and
you know
what we say in the book about the fact
that it's always spring in your house
and that that's really what we're
talking about we're not talking about
either anything that violates any known
law the spring in your house doesn't
violate any known law because when it's
hot out
we cool your house with an air
conditioner that slightly heats your
backyard right it all makes sense you
just keep the coolness on one side of
the wall
and and as we talked about on on rogan
uh when you change your diet to
something that is better for you your
your
physiology and the gut microbiome that
you have on board actually changes so
that you come to appreciate the thing
better and what he raised which hadn't
occurred to me but the but the way of
marking progress in martial arts being a
change of color in the in the belt that
you have
adds value without coming with much of a
cost and that's you know that those are
the sorts of solutions and and the same
thing with pride and craftsmanship that
we also that we also talk about in that
section that i read from um that um
finding
finding value not just in the minimalist
reductionist uh version of what the
thing is well all i need is a chair and
therefore i need something that holds me
up when i try to sit
okay
um are there other things that a chair
could offer you that would provide more
value and the construction of which
would therefore also provide more value
for the person constructing it of course
there are we've all sat in garbage
chairs and and better chairs regardless
of how you know of your surroundings
you've sat in variable quality chairs
and the quality isn't just about the
comfort it's also about the level of
construction and you can intuit
something about what the thought was
that went into it yeah whether it's
garbage chairs or garbage trucks i mean
you know the fact some of us have not
sat in garbage trucks uh except by that
use of the term garbage i guess right
yeah
one way or the other i had a it wasn't a
garbage truck but i had a not too
awesome truck there for a while yeah
yeah back in grad school it was okay it
was all right it was yeah but uh
yeah it went from here and often got to
there it usually it usually does yeah
f-150 for those of you who wonder um
anyway an old one though
people used to say friends don't let
friends drive forwards
i do it so we actually
i have no idea whether that still
applies right yeah before well we
started hearing that after we were
literally in a ford bronco that caught
fire in the middle of nebraska in a
snowstorm and we had to abandon it there
um which is a story for another time but
then much later i ended up with this uh
ford f-150 that was old and you know
rusty and michigan and all this but it
it got me from here to there yeah and i
often got my bike there too so it was it
was fine
[Music]